[Music]  anything you can tell us about the new  season of breaking bad oh wow uh  it's the dirtiest one yet it's it's very  violent i'm sure there may or may not be  a lot of deaths but um it's very insane  wow and it's just you ever feel like you  get the scripts and you're as a viewer i  watch right and i and and like a lot of  us every season every episode it  ratchets up and ratchets up and i can't  believe it as as someone who's on the  show you get the script yeah i mean long  before you shoot it no we get it right  before we start shooting and i'm such a  huge fan of the show as well so i cannot  wait to read the next script and  they just get bigger and bigger and just  darker and darker so it's going to be  very dark well the new season of  breaking bad premieres july 15th on amc  i will be there a lot of us will be  there you got to check this show out  aaron paul thanks so much always a  pleasure